let's start off just talking about the
issue of tracking people looking at
decks just as an issue
how do you think about that and how do
you frame it with
people who use the product and then
customers who maybe are privacy
sensitive
privacy sensitive yeah it's a it's a
great question um
and it's a it's a thorny one too right
because it's really at the
the sender's discretion what they want
and
i i certainly didn't agree that for for
some materials it's
you know you do want to have a local
copy and the sender can always turn on
downloading and once you download we
stop
tracking it's just in the browser so
we're not doing tracking at any level
that is
kind of above and beyond what any other
website would do we're just taking a
document making into a website and
you know showing engagement information
and for some people that's really
critical and valuable
um oftentimes in fundraising where we
get used the most
is or the beginning part is just that
pitch deck that gets you the meeting or
not
and there are a few things that are
unintuitive there about
why analytics are helpful that document
gets updated a lot
like you jason are looking at these
things really fast on average investors
only spend
but it used to be three and a half
minutes per pitch deck now it's down to
three minutes per pitch deck during the
pandemic
it's a whole other story but then you
know there's a lot writing on that the
founder is updating it a lot so if i
send you
you know an attachment which is my deck
and then i don't hear from you for three
days but now i've suddenly updated a
bunch of stuff in there
do i send you the new one i don't even
know if you looked at the old one and
it's just kind of an awkward way to
start off so i can see if you've looked
at it
i can update it i never have to tell you
that i updated the thing so you
basically have this way of controlling
who's seen what and having this audit
trail and the per page analytics are
useful sometimes but
but more just like um you know do you
look at it did you care
so the flip side of this is that when
you spend time reading someone's deck
you're giving that founder
a really big compliment because you're
giving them your time so
you know in some instances you're like
yeah i don't really want to know but
it does dissuade um a practice where
like investors will just forward decks
to other investors
yeah that is completely unfair and
you're protecting them there and
it really is helpful as you're saying to
know that the deck was opened
and it's helpful to know how what pages
people dropped off on or they zipped
forward or they zipped back
and in fact i i was literally
getting prepared for the podcast this
morning and i realized oh my lord
i'm a double hypocrite uh number one
i love that i i i love what you do for
my founders so they can tell me
yeah you know five people in the at this
venture firm opened our deck we sent it
to them and
they've been in it like 10 times right i
just updated it the partner says i'm
going to send it to
my other partners and then they don't do
that or they do that and that tells you
everything about how really engaged they
are you know and how likely they are to
lead the round
it's a new year it's a fresh start and
you've got your small business over here
your medium-sized business and
you are now shifting business hours
maybe you're hiring more remote
employees
but the one thing that remains unchanged
in the sea of change that we just
experienced in 2020
and let's face it 2021 is still gonna
have a lot of change especially the
first half well you need
to have the right people on your team
this is going to be a constant no matter
what happens in the world
talent is the most important thing for
you as the founder
and the best way to hire people we all
know this
you know this i know it it's linkedin
jobs they can get you qualified
candidates
and they're going to find you the right
person quickly and most people say
listen you can have quality or you can
have speed
you know what with linkedin jobs you get
quality and you get speed
that's the magic of it they have over
722 million members worldwide
and getting started is super easy on
linkedin jobs
all of these features that they've
created are designed to help you get
high quality candidates and when you
post your job you can put screening
questions i love those
and linkedin will quickly get those
screening questions
in front of the right people and you can
do this all from your mobile device now
if you're on the run we're hiring a
bunch of people for my company launch
guess where we're finding the best
candidates i'll wait for you okay yep
that's right linkedin jobs of course
it's lightning jobs when your business
is ready
to make that next hire find the right
person with linkedin jobs you can pay
what you want and get the first 50 off
at linkedin.com twist that's right 50
bucks for your first job posting is
waiting for you right now at
linkedin.comtwist
linkedin.com twist terms and conditions
do apply because they're giving you 50.